44 millionen passagiere
400 tausend starts und landungen
[Musik]
35.000 beschäftigte
am ersten fünf sterne flughafen europas
jede stunde starten und landen hier bis
zu 90 flugzeuge aber nur wenn alles nach
plan läuft
der kleinste fehler kann den gesamten
betrieb lahm legen das ist schlecht
was passiert hinter den kulissen des
münchner flughafens
[Musik]
fünf uhr früh ein neuer tag am franz
josef strauß flughafen in münchen
flug lh 731 aus hongkong ist gerade
gelandet
der airbus a380 ist der erste von mehr
als 1100 flügen an diesem tag
[Musik]
rund 120.000 passagiere werden heute das
drehkreuz nutzen
der flughafen münchen liegt rund 30
kilometer nordöstlich der bayerischen
landeshauptstadt im erdinger moos
auf dem mehr als 1500 hektar großen
gelände stehen die beiden hauptterminal
sowie ein satelliten gebäude das zu
terminal 2 gehört
zwischen den beiden hauptthemen nls
steht der tower
hier oben sitzen die lotsen der
deutschen flugsicherung
die an fluglotsen kontrollieren jede
flugbewegung im luftraum
die platz kontrolle erteilt start und
landefreigaben
und diroll kontrolle ist für die
maschinen auf den rollfeldern
verantwortlich
[Musik]
matthias antlinger arbeitet als
supervisor im
obersten stock des kontrollturms
rund 75 meter über dem erdboden
[Musik]
guten morgen
ist es
soweit ganz gut 26 mal ein bier sie
umgesetzt
und länger muss gleich eine
doppelaufgabe meistern er koordiniert
die abläufe im kontrollturm und erteilt
den maschinen ihre start und
landeerlaubnis
spricht die vier lose arbeitsplätze und
die beiden kehren viele wie die
arbeitsplätze dass jeder lotse maximal
zwei stunden am stück arbeitsplatzes und
danach mindestens eine halbe stunde
pause hat für jeden staat und für jede
landung braucht der pilot die freigabe
eines lotsen der lotse ist wie ein
verkehrspolizist der all diese
kreuzungen überwacht und dafür sorgt wer
der erste und wer der zweite ist es gibt
also keine rechts vor links und keine
roten ampeln sondern hier gilt das wort
des nutzen wer ist der erste wer ist der
zweite
am münchner flughafen können beide
rollbahnen gleichermaßen für starts und
landungen verwendet werden die lotsen
tragen enorme verantwortung
sie müssen bis zu fünf maschinen
gleichzeitig im auge behalten das geht
nur mit höchster konzentration und
ausreichend pausen um den kopf wieder
frei zu kriegen
der tower lotse informiert anleger
welche starts und landungen anstehen
während der pause trägt antlinger dann
alleine die verantwortung für den
südlichen teil des airports
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier den arbeitsplatz mit
übernommen sprich ich bin zuständig für
die südliche stadt und landebahn und den
umgebenden luftraum um diese
trainer
antlinger informiert die piloten über
die aktuellen windverhältnisse auf dem
rollfeld so können sie sich zum beispiel
auf shervin der beim landeanflug
einstellen
im anflug der eine ist ihr kurz vorm
aufsetzen lufthansa airbus 319
der nächste ist schon bei fünf meilen
und zwischendrin startet jetzt die wäre
ja eh schon die anweisung gegeben ob auf
die piste zu gehen
starts und landungen kommen hier schlag
auf schlag
die iberia maschine muss das hat jetzt
schnell in die luft
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt also die freigabe zum
abflug gegeben
es sollte sich auch nicht allzu viel
zeit lassen weil die nächste maschine
jetzt schon bei drei meilen es spricht
der landet in eineinhalb minuten
die iberia setzt zum start an
der flughafen ist ein wichtiges
drehkreuz in der region kurz und
mittelstreckenflieger bringen passagiere
aus anderen deutschen städten oder dem
europäischen nachbarländern nach münchen
der langstrecke geht es von hier aus zu
zielen rund um die welt
die maschinen sollen nur so kurz wie
möglich am boden bleiben und
verspätungen zu vermeiden arbeiten alle
abteilungen wie ein uhrwerk zu sein
auf dem rollfeld sorgen die lademeister
dafür dass alles glatt läuft sie sind
zur stelle wenn irgend etwas hakt oder
eine premiere ansteht so wie heute
franz eder ist einer der beiden
lademeister im dienst heute muss er zum
ersten mal einen airbus
a350 1000 in empfang nehmen noch nie ist
dieser flugzeugtyp auf dem münchner
airport gelandet
mit 73 8 metern ist die maschine knapp
einen meter länger als ein a380 800
und wie sich zeigt fast zu lang für die
äußerste parkposition
[Musik]
die rote linie ist die absolute rote
linie überdies darf nichts drüber
allerdings häufig und diese position und
der rollweg ist für jeden tabu also da
derzeit ist er muss absolut
hindernisfreiheit und durchsetzt hat
sehr an der grinten wir haben jetzt
genau
erkannten und aus sicherheitsgründen da
die jetzt zur forschung dass man
mindestens ein haltepunkt am meter nach
vorne verlegt
so steht der nächsten landung nicht zum
weg
[Musik]
8 uhr früh mittlerweile geht es an
beiden terminals sowie im taubenschlag
auch wenn es beim entladen noch nach
überschaubaren gepäck aussieht im
terminal kann es sich schnell zu einer
wahren koffer flut an starben
das gepäckband nimmt einen großteil des
erdgeschosses im terminal 2 1
insgesamt ist das förderband hier 46
kilometer lang von der haupthalle führt
ein tunnel zum satelliten gebäude die
gesamtkapazität liegt bei 80.000
gepäckstücken pro tag in beiden
terminals
von gepäckwagen geht es erstmal auf ein
förderband
es gibt unzählige formen von koffern und
taschen
damit alles sicher ankommt wird jedes
stück in eine wanne gepackt
zu stoßzeiten können fast 12.000
gepäckstücke pro stunde transportiert
werden aber nicht alle fluggäste reisen
sofort ab oder weiter für sie gibt es
ein gigantisches gepäckaufbewahrung
system
bis zu 4.500 koffer können am münchner
flughafen gleichzeitig gelagert werden
sie bleiben in den regalen bis ihre
besitzer weiterfliegen
[Musik]
der rest wird innerhalb von minuten zur
gepäckausgabe gebracht und von den
passagieren die in münchen aussteigen
abgeholt
[Musik]
das gepäck system wird streng überwacht
wie viele bereiche am flughafen
von manchen kontrollen bekommen die
reisenden kaum etwas mit
andere können jeden treffen
auf dem weg von der gepäckausgabe nach
draußen müssen alle passagiere durch den
zoll
vorbei an dem leitenden zollbeamten
david schewski und seinem kollegen
christoph otto
die beiden polizisten arbeiten schon
seit jahren hier und sie sind nicht ohne
grund mit waffe und schusssichere weste
ausgestattet
[Musik]
2017 hat der münchner zoll allein 950
kilogramm rauschgift sichergestellt
[Musik]
tja houston ganzen an die maschinen
kommen jetzt gleich dann hätten wir hier
eine frankfurter umsteiger die
basel
und johannesburg kommt
zwischen sieben und elf uhr vormittags
treffen am münchner flughafen viele
internationale flüge ein jeder passagier
muss durch diese schleuse gehen grün
bedeutet nichts zu verzollen der rote
schalter ist für reisende mit
anmeldepflichtigen waren im gepäck die
zollfahnder halten nach möglichen
schmugglern ausschau aber auch nach
leuten wem nicht klar ist dass sie zum
zoll müssen
einen grünstreifen an der seite auf dem
label am koffer
alles was außerhalb von der eu kommt hat
kein streifen sprich es nur weiß und
darauf achten wir in erster linie darauf
daran erkennen wir im endeffekt die
flugroute vor allem reisende aus asien
und den usa kennen sich oft nicht so gut
mit den eu bestimmungen aus
guten tag die damen sie kommen woher
bitte des schönen tag noch
dieser fluggast aus den usa weiß dass er
seine schusswaffe anmelden muss
die leiterin dieser chinesischen
reisegruppe wird von otto hingegen
stichprobenartig kontrolliert ohne
konkreten verdacht
[Musik]
am nebentisch kontrolliert da wird es
das schewski unterdessen eine frau aus
kamerun
daher kommen jetzt aus einem
afrikanischen land das müsste man
schauen was ich alles ein für
theoretisch alles dabei sein von
verbotenen lebensmitteln bis das
rauschgift
müsste man einfach mal schauen halt das
ist jetzt wahrscheinlich so eine art e
wer gewinnt
wer mehr als 10.000 euro bargeld im
gepäck hat muss das anmelden auch teure
elektrogeräte müssen durch den zoll
drogen und frische tierische
lebensmittel wie fleisch wurst oder käse
dürfen überhaupt nicht in die eu
eingeführt werden
[Musik]
für die zollfahnder sind die kontrollen
oft eine begegnung mit anderen kulturen
[Musik]
so etwas haben wir hier getrocknete
es halt so wie jene technik hat auch
ihren bedenklich aber ja es ist gut
dass
sie machen wie unterschiedlich die
kulturen auch sind ja
flusskrebse exotische suppen im gepäck
finden sich die seltsamsten dinge
auch christof otto muss immer wieder
staunen
[Musik]
viele polen sind dabei viele steinchen
ich kann auch nicht immer bei jedem
reisenden bei jedem kleinsten wohl was
ich finde immer gleich darum tests
durchführen man darf natürlich nicht
immer jeden gleich kriminalisieren und
sagen wort da ist irgendwas dann schaut
aus wie drogen deswegen müssen wir ab
und zu mal riechen ab und zu mal schauen
mal genauer schauen aber das was die
damals dabei hat ist alles wirklich
komplett in ordnung
während die kölner nach verbotenen
stoffen fahnden können die reisenden am
flughafen ganz legalen substanzen frönen
im airbräu
[Musik]
12 uhr mittags die perfekte zeit um im
restaurant ein paar bayerische
spezialitäten zu genießen
zusammen mit einem ganz besonderen
schmankerl das direkt vor ort
hergestellt wird
[Musik]
der münchner flughafen ist der einzige
airport der welt mit eigener brauerei
auf der karte stehen bis zu acht
bierspezialitäten
das helle trägt den namen flieger quell
das haus gebaute hefe weißbier heißt
cumulus
bayern und das bier ein klischee mit dem
der flughafenbetreiber gerne spielt der
airport sieht sich selbst als bayerns
tor zur welt
2017 haben mehr als 44 millionen
passagiere den ersten fünf sterne
flughafen europas genutzt die fluggast
zahlen steigen seit jahren an
immer mehr reisen bekommen aus fernen
ländern ausserhalb des schengenraums
das bedeutet mehr personal für
personenkontrollen an flughäfen sind
nicht nur drehkreuze für reisende
sondern auch für kriminelle oder leute
die sich den behörden entziehen wollen
passkontrolle patrouillen gänge
identitäts checks
dienstgruppenleiter laut meyer und sein
kollege benjamin könig haben am terminal
1 viel zu tun
die beiden beamten gehören zu den rund
1200 bundespolizisten am flughafen
münchen
englisch ist viele passports blies
die drei jungen männer können keine
pässe vorweisen nur eine
aufenthaltsgenehmigung
aber ist die auch gültig
das ist außer form
also wenn ich jemanden kontrolleure dann
schaue ich erst einmal zunächst nach
hause war peter kommentator das dokument
gültig ist
was er
außer dem dokument gegebenenfalls noch
braucht für einen legalen aufenthalt in
deutschland und wenn ich dann grünes
licht habe wo ich sage so weit passt es
dann muss ich telefonieren und dann wird
die person entsprechen in unserem system
abgefragt ob irgendwas vorliegt
die papiere sind gültig aber die frage
bleibt ob es nicht doch ein problem gibt
[Musik]
nach dem telefonat ist klar alles okay
einer der jungen männer möchte in sein
heimatland zurückfliegen die anderen
beiden sind hier um ihn zu verabschieden
die kontrollen von personen hinsichtlich
ihrem rechtlichen status ist schon sehr
komplex also das heißt da auch für
unseren die mitarbeiter das natürlich
ständig auf dem laufenden halten müssen
aber dass die rechte konzentration
angeht aber auch die unterschiedlichen
passen weil es kommen laufend neue pässe
raus auch manchmal sind die rechtlichen
situation neu deswegen ist auch ein
großer park von unserer arbeit dass wir
uns auch laufend halten und entsprechend
für bildungsmaßnahmen werden auch
dementsprechend durchgegriffen
nun warten die beiden bundespolizisten
auf den nächsten schwung passagiere
[Musik]
13 uhr am flughafen münchen herrscht
hochbetrieb
zahlreicher maschinenbau anlanden und
entladen werden aber zu solchen
stoßzeiten sind die passagier brücken
oft belegt
lademeister franz eder muss ein problem
lösen eine der brücken ist defekt
die passagiere sitzen seit zehn minuten
in ihrem flieger fest
der weg über gangway und busse würde
viel länger dauern ärgerlich für die
passagiere und ein logistik problem für
den flughafen durch die verspätung
müssten womöglich anschlussflüge
verschoben werden
nach kurzem bahnen gibt der techniker
grünes licht die brücke funktioniert die
da
um die gesamten abläufe im terminal 2
kümmert sich ein team im sogenannten hub
operations center kurz
der flughafen münchen gehört zu den
größten drehkreuzen europas und jörg
abel ist dafür verantwortlich dass alle
verbindungen reibungslos laufen wie
geplant
gibt es doch eine verspätung müssen die
mitarbeiter versuchen die wartezeit wie
die passagiere so kurz wie möglich zu
halten
hier sehen wir die umsteige ströme
führen hat typisch wir wollen unsere
passagiere von a nach b bringen also im
hat müssen die gäste umsteigen und wir
schauen ganz genau ob die gäste auch
ihre umsteigeflüge so erreichen wie wir
es gerne hätten und das machen wir mit
diesem tool hier dort können wir genau
sehen für einen einzelnen flug was sind
alles die
umsteigeflüge auf die unsere passagiere
umsteigen und wir können an der
farbgebung sehen welcher umsteige strom
also welcher passagier
erreicht sein flug in normaler zeit das
sind die grünen bereich und die flüge
die gelb sind da ist es etwas kritischer
da überlegen wir uns ob wir den gast
entsprechend schneller befördern damit
er seinen anschlussflug noch erreicht
im tower machen sich die lotsen
unterdessen bereit für die nächste
stoßzeit diesmal bei den abflügen
[Applaus]
viele maschinen mit internationalen
zielen warten schon in der startposition
alle wollen praktisch gleichzeitig
abheben
staus können nur durch rechtzeitige um
planung vermieden werden der supervisor
matthias antlinger lässt auf dem
südlichen rollfeld nur noch starts zu
jetzt ist es also soweit wir haben jetzt
bereits 15 maschinen für die südbahn
klassen zum abflug die anflüge werden
langsam weniger so dass ich jetzt mal
schauen dass mit den rest der anflüge
auf die neue planung der regierung
werden
hallo die high speed wegen asics nein
die levels bitte auf die nordbahn
dankeschön
antlinger erteilt jetzt starb
genehmigungen im fünf minuten takt
[Musik]
in einer serie selber dort oft verdeckt
hallo lufthansa 76 von line up to six
lufthansa vor vfb wind tree wannsee
release notes name to six white klärt
vortag departure angenehme reise
linke 25 den thunersee romantischer
musik erklärt verteilt
[Musik]
nach einer stunde ist die rushhour
überstanden und antlinger macht seine
vorgeschriebene pause
auch nach 35 jahren im dienst macht ihm
sein job bei der flugsicherung freude
[Musik]
das ist eigentlich wunderschön von oben
runterkommt man sieht leute wo man der
maschine gerade noch die lande freigabe
gegeben hat die jetzt mit ihrem gepäck
ihr ankommen runde andy s bahn gehen
oder leute die unten aus selbst bei
rauskommen die tafeln für den abflug
checken und mehr weiß genau wie man da
wieder hoben es gibt mir der maschine
die take off klären sie wolle keinen
urlaub fliegen ist geht ihm gut alles
toll
bei der zollabfertigung ist nach der
mittagszeit auch ein wenig ruhe
eingekehrt
aber dieser karton eines us passagierjet
doch arbeit bedeuten vermutet david
schewski
das vorkommen sind wir haben
bei dem
heft
ist hier
ist der schewski muss den wert der
flaschen schätzen
dem fluggast droht vielleicht ein
bußgeld
andere haben eine schönere ankunft in
münchen die betreiber setzen auf eine
möglichst angenehme atmosphäre
offenbar mit erfolg ein britisches
luftfahrtforschungsinstitut hat münchen
zum ersten fünf sterne airport europas
gekürt unter anderem wegen der klaren
und übersichtlichen beschilderung
aber auch der shopping und gastronomie
bereich mit seinen 150 leben und 60
restaurant betrieben konnte punkten
der centermanager phillip arens ist für
das richtige wohlfühl ambiente zuständig
[Musik]
so wir sind hier am flughafen münchen
natürlich ein großes ab und da ist es
nicht nur wichtig dass die
operationellen prozesse passen sondern
auch die shoppingwelt 50 prozent unserer
umsätze werden mit shopping gemacht wir
versuchen die passagiere auch so zu
führen dass wir impulse auslösen können
das sagen sie nähmen im duty-free noch
einmal irgendwie eine kleinigkeit mit
sie gehen in eine andere einheit kaufen
sich noch eine uhr und irgendwelche
anziehsachen anzüge was auch immer wir
versuchen hier alles zu bedienen eine
breite spektrum abzubilden weil wir
natürlich enorm viel verkehr haben
sowohl von abfliegenden passagieren als
auch um steigenden passagieren die sich
hier im transit befinden
im schnitt strömen hier pro tag mehr als
120.000 passagiere durch an spitzentagen
sogar bis zu 150.000
für die geschäftsleute sind vor allem
die reisenden transitbereich interessant
das warten auf den anschlussflug lässt
sich schließlich auch mit shopping
verkürzen
[Musik]
es ist so dass wir versuchen die
passagiere natürlich zentral durch die
ganzen gastronomie und shopping
einheiten zu führen das auch sehr
spezifisch machen auch mit der
positionierung und den erkenntnissen die
wir haben was ist das shopping verhalten
der passagiere was benötigen die was
möchten sie gerne kaufen dementsprechend
positionieren wir die passagiere und
haben auch so dann die wege führen so
lässt sich auf dem weg zum gate noch ein
einkaufsbummel einschieben
15 uhr kurz und mittelstreckenflieger
haben in der letzten stunde viele
passagiere nach münchen gebracht die zu
fernzielen weiterreisen wollen den
flughafen steht die große rushhour am
abend bevor
münchen kann etwa 1300 starts und
landungen pro tag stemmen
[Musik]
nun geht die langstreckenmaschinen an
den start
unter anderem das größte
passagierflugzeug der welt der airbus
a380 800 wird für einen langen flug
vorbereitet
fünf dieser riesenjets pendeln täglich
zwischen münchen und zielen in
nordamerika und asien
gepäck treibstoff frachtgut
der ramp agent michael aula ist für die
gesamte beladung zuständig
zuerst muss er die registrierung
überprüfen im luftfahrt alphabet heißt
die maschine mit dem taufnamen
johannesburg
über diese gelben schläuche wird kalte
luft aus dem terminal ins flugzeug punkt
die treibstoffmenge muss genau berechnet
werden entscheidend dafür ist das
startgewicht und welche windverhältnisse
für den flug vorhergesagt sind
[Musik]
fries electric für unseren flug heute
nach peking wurden 141 5 tonnen aktuell
an bord sind wir bei 121 tonnen das
heißt wir brauchen ungefähr noch 20
tonnen bis das flugzeug fertig und
vollgetankt ist
während michael lohner den a380 für den
start vorbereitet plant das team im hub
operations center schon ein paar stunden
weiter
die flugrouten für die nächsten ankünfte
müssen festgelegt werden manchmal sogar
bevor die maschine überhaupt vom
startflughafen abgehoben hat
also hier sehen wir zb unseren rückflug
von singapur nach münchen dieser flug
wurde mit einer anderen flugroute
versehen warum haben wir das getan das
kann man sehr schön am system sehen
zeigt es mal
das ist singapur dort steht uns ein
flugzeug noch das wird dann nachher
diese flugroute südlich durch indien
führen und dann hier hoch richtung
europa fliegen das ist in münchen
gelandet normalerweise geht die
flugroute viel weiter nördlich entlang
diesmal war dies aber nicht möglich weil
dieses bunte was sie hier sehen sind
starke gewitter die über nordindien
herrschen und die müssen entsprechend
umflogen werden
15 30 die abendlichen rush-hour beginnt
schon am nachmittag die passagiere für
den flug nach peking checken ein
hunderte koffer und taschen müssen in
den a380 geladen werden auch das gepäck
der transit reisenden dass er dem morgen
im lager auf den anschlussflug gewartet
hat
[Musik]
jeder koffer wird noch einmal gescannt
und dann in container verladen
in jedem von ihnen kommen höchstens 40
gepäckstücke falls ein fluggast nicht
auftaucht kann sein gepäck so schnell
identifiziert und aussortiert werden die
restlichen koffer bleiben bis zu ihrem
zielort peking im container
[Musik]
aber nicht nur privat gepäck geht auf
reisen auch eine menge luftfracht muss
mit nach peking
michael hauser vergleicht die angaben
auf seinem laden zettel mit der
packliste
[Musik]
so das gewicht dieser einheit stimmt
bewogen mit 3400 96 kilo
geladen werden soll sie auf position 22
papa das ist im flugzeug im vorderen
laderaum die hinterste position da kommt
so hin ich guck doch mal die einheit
auch flugfähig ist
nicht nur das richtige gewicht ist
entscheidend die ladung muss so verstaut
werden dass sie nicht verrutschen kann
eine plötzliche gewichtsverlagerung in
der luft könnte den flug in gefahr
bringen
aber hier passt alles paula gibt die
fracht frei
[Musik]
zum schluss überprüft er nochmal die
verankerung
am zoll wartet der us passagier
unterdessen dass es auch für ihn
weitergeht
[Musik]
zahlbar sofort
nur dann kann der gast aus den usa mit
seinem karton nach deutschland
einreisten
2017 hat der münchner zoll gut eine
milliarde euro an zöllen und
einfuhrumsatzsteuer erhoben
[Gelächter]
immerhin ist er ohne strafverfahren
davon gekommen
16 uhr
die abfertigungshalle wimmelt jetzt
voran und abreisenden passagieren
die beiden bundespolizisten benjamin
könig und lothar reitmeier halten nach
unbeaufsichtigt im gepäck ausschau
bei den mietwagen schaltern werden sie
für mich drei koffer stehen
mutterseelenallein im gang
die beamten müssen schnellstens klären
wem das gepäck gehört oder ob vielleicht
ein anschlag drohen könnte
psychologisch
die lage schwer
es ist schlecht
da ist es schlecht
die polizei muss immer vom schlimmsten
ausgehen in den koffern könnte ja auch
eine bombe sein
der bereich wird sofort geräumt und
abgesperrt
dann müssten die sprengstoffspürhunde
und bond mensch erfahren aber soweit
kommt es diesmal nicht
offenbar ist der besitzer doch noch
aufgetaucht
reithmayer liest in die leviten
[Musik]
jetzt mal ja ich hab mit dem always you
genau das ist part i have put
geputscht und
haben eine abfrage
dann die wahl zwischen
der kampf geschah ist fisch gestempelt
da geht es lang geht
ein bußgeld für das koffer stehen lassen
gibt es am münchner flughafen nicht und
natürlich erst recht nicht für mangelnde
englischkenntnisse
die beladung des airbus a380 nach peking
läuft unterdessen auf hochtouren
[Musik]
insgesamt sind es aktuell bei uns
geworden fast 550 gepäckstücke diese
werden jetzt noch entsprechend der
ladekran verladen und dann sollten wir
hoffentlich ja entsprechend hat
pünktlich hier die position verlassen
den letzten außen checks führt der pilot
selbst durch vorher fliegt die maschine
irgendwohin
flugkapitän roland op muss vor dem start
prüfen ob sein flugzeug absolut sicher
ist
[Musik]
ja
damit macht es geht einmal komplett
turnverein programm endete wieder an dem
punkt hier schauen wir uns vor dem
sensor kann die extrem wichtig das sind
so die flugdaten die dürfen
auch nicht verstopft das situativ und
mir
unfälle machen aber das was hat sie den
kampf versuchen
[Musik]
supermärkten
da schauen wir uns enorm und
allgemeinzustand an also sollte passiert
nicht sehen wollten die karte so dass
abgeworfen
die lampen
die berge schaut man halt dass sie nicht
verboten sind
ein doppelschlag dabei
die tour und den riesenairbus herum
dauert gut 15 minuten
dann gibt kapitän der og grünes licht
außen check bestanden
[Musik]
16 42 meldung vom kontrollzentrum schon
wieder ein herrenloser koffer
könig und reitmeier prüfen das gepäck
das anscheinend schon etwas länger da
steht
da machen wir jetzt mal
also minimum halbe stunde stehen ja dann
okay der kollege ist er los und holt
absperrband ja schon mal das schon
ausdruck
ausgerufen wurde ist
irgendwas darauf erkennbar von
besitzer nichts
reithmayer gibt im lagebericht durch
am münchner flughafen werden jeden tag
bis zu 20 herrenlose gepäckstücke
gefunden und die bundespolizei muss bei
jedem koffer ihr standardprogramm
durchziehen auch wenn es dem betrieb
aufhält
[Musik]
wir müssen mit allem rechnen ist kann
natürlich sein was wahrscheinlicher ist
dass tatsächlich jemand seinen koffer
einfach nur vergessen hat es könnte aber
auch sein dass wenn jemand weiß was er
tut dass er das so aussehen lässt als
würde er einfach ein ganz normales
harmloses gepäckstück könnte sich
natürlich auch um was anderes handeln
das müssen wir als untersuchungen
deswegen werden wir voraussichtlich je
nachdem wie der lothar das entscheidet
die spezialkräfte anfordern also hund
und schärfer und dann schauen wir mal
weiter was ich jetzt entwickelt
natürlich ist die sensibilisierung im
öffentlichen bereich in dem wir uns
jetzt befinden eine ganz andere als wenn
wir hinter der sicherheitskontrolle
gerne deswegen wie man sieht sperren wir
jetzt hier auch weitere mich ab einfach
nur um auf nummer sicher zu gehen
am airbus a380 nach peking werden
unterdessen die letzten container
verladen
[Musik]
erst wenn alles sicher verstaut ist kann
der ramp agent seine liste mit der des
piloten abgleichen
[Musik]
was ist dem kapitän über geben in diesem
falle sind meine lade gewichte die
abschlusszahlen er bekommt das über
satellit über so landtag us-system ins
cockpit geschossen das wird dort
ausgedruckt und dann werden wir
entsprechend ein vergleich der daten
vornehmen der notwendig ist um das
flugzeug auf strecke zu schicken
mit der übergabe ist das pflicht erfüllt
[Musik]
dann hören wir arbeiten ja gerne eins
sollte es seien ja aber einen tank und
abschluss insgesamt oder
467 gäste + 1 in film tron keinesfalls
von unserer seite aus ja wunderschön und
was ihnen da war uns ganz herzlich danke
die zusammenarbeit sehr gerne zum
nächsten mal prima wissen extra guten
flug
flug lh 772 nach peking ist jetzt fast
startklar es fehlt nur noch ein paar
passagiere
im terminal warten das team reithmayer
und könig auf das spezialkommando die
ersten experten sind schon da
sprengstoffspuren telli und ihr herrchen
[Musik]
wie findet keinen hinweis auf
sprengstoff
plötzlich taucht ein mann auf der sagt
dass der koffer ihm gehöre
aber so schnell kommt er da jetzt nicht
mehr raus
die sprengstoff kontrolle wird ganz nach
vorschrift fortgesetzt
[Musik]
der entschärfer führt einen technischen
check durch
dann erst öffnet er den koffer
und wurde seinem pass irgendwo ja er
meint ja ist es drin verschlossen wenn
ich denn sonst selber mal bronze
[Musik]
erst nach dem blick in dem pass ist klar
der mann ist tatsächlich der koffer
besitzer und reitmeier ist stinksauer
endlich können die beamten den bereich
wieder freigeben der einsatz hat eine
stunde gedauert
dann gehen wir natürlich schon
sind sehr sensibel mit seiner gegen
stellung weil wir natürlich nicht wissen
was tun ist wir können nicht reinschauen
entsprechen einmal abgesperrt unsere
maßnahmen eingeleitet und bis dahin noch
mein puls war relativ ruhig der hat sich
dann etwas älter als der besitzer
eintraf und sagt er das als eine stunde
beim essen war und
das teil vergessen hat obwohl er nicht
das erste mal flog sondern des f10
fliegt und eigentlich wissen müsste dass
man so was schlicht und ergreifend nicht
macht
die gedankenlosigkeit mancher passagiere
gehört zum berufsalltag von jutta
reitmeier und benjamin könig aber für
heute haben sie erst mal feierabend
18 uhr im terminal 2 huston die letzten
passagiere zu ihrem flug lh 722 nach
peking
wie viele andere kommen sie direkt von
einem zubringer flug und gerade noch
rechtzeitig
[Musik]
wir haben für diesen flug über 50
verschiedene umsteiger zubringerflüge
gehabt und da das bringt das system ganz
schön an die an die spitze des veedels
mal herausfordern
endlich heißt es boarding abgeschlossen
der a380 wird zurückgesetzt
[Musik]
die maschine wiegt 5 144 tonnen
nur 16 tonnen weniger als das maximale
startgewicht
den start dieses riesenvogels
vorzubereiten war eine technische und
logistische herausforderung
und doch ist es nur eine von vielen
aufgaben am münchner flughafen
im schnitt starten und landen hier
täglich 1000 100 flugzeuge
bis zu 150.000 fluggäste werden hier
abgefertigt
gut das ist nur möglich wenn alle hand
in hand arbeiten
[Musik]